[Music]
we're here in the village of Sardar in
the province of Kandahar in Afghanistan
we've just had a fantastic meeting with
a group of Village elders and farmers
and a Farmers Association to talk about
some of the many challenges they're
facing in this country which has been
facing now over 35 years of Warf for
what is really interesting with these
Farmers is to discover how aware they
are of the challenges they're facing
we've talked a lot about water water
scarcity we've talked about crops we've
talked about the soil problems markets
but what's most amazing to me is their
awareness of the fact that their
agricultural systems need to change to
evolve to adapt to what they're facing
climate change here we've just finished
looking at a check Dam which will help
them to prevent too much water flow in
their in their land to prevent erosion
and we'll also recharge groundwater this
is an important project that was funded
by the World Bank and implemented
through FAO uh one of almost 7,000 check
dams that FAO has done in the country
country they want to move into uh
Horticultural crops they realize that
farming systems must evolve um but for
us as FAO the most precious part here is
the fact that they already know what
these challenges are and we can support
them we can help them with so many ways
but we're pushing on an open door they
already know so much of what it's
[Music]
about